*(music)*
*(throwing up noise )*
MY NEW COMPANY
B3
BIG BOUNCY BOOBIES
alright who's got the biggest titties?
flat chest Zoey
GET THE FUCK OUT!!!!!
GET THE FUCK OUT ZOEY!!!!!
Kiana
*swooshing sound*
you got that ass, but GET OUT!!
WHAT THE FUCK DO YOU TAKE ME FOR !!!!
WE'RE CALLED BIG TITTY TITTIES!!!!!
Nikki, you look like you're from tumblr
*spits*
I despise you
i hate your guts
*spits*
But business is business
and you're hired Nikki
Billy you're in
*fart noise*
ok we got Lilanni
she's asian fla - FLAT CHEST!!!!!
LILANNI!!!!
WHY DO YOU SHOW UP EVEN ???!!!!!
GET OUT !!!!!
alright zoey
ZOEY!!!!
WE HAD THIS TALK BEFORE !!!!
it's time to hire another one
ok we got Lillian
she's teen, tatoos
FUCK OFF FUCK OFF LILLIAN!!!!
why is this so hard?
alright were hiring her
you better get some implants
alright what her cup size? B tha-
*pewds burps *
where are all the big breasted women?
FINALLY !!!!!
A GIFT FROM THE GODS!!!
Candice!!!!!
*titty slap noise*
you're in
fuck sake you're all useless
1 dollar per hour
Kiana you're in
Tiffany !!
one dollar an hour
TIFFANY YOU'RE IN !!
YOU'RE IN, NOW BUY ME SHOES
OMG ZOEY
HOW MANY TIMES ARE YOU TRYING ??!!!!
HOW MANY FUCKING TIMES DO I GOTTA TELL YOU ZOEY  !!!!!!!!
GET THE FUCK OUT AND STOP WASTING  MY TIME!!!!!!!
YOU GOT ZERO POTENTIAL !!!!
ZERO !!!!
hey tifanny
wear this but plug while you go shopping
tiffany says: leave it to me
Mmmmm.
BUTT PLUG !!!!!!
ALRIGHT ZOEY YOU WANNA WORK IN THIS BUSINESS SO HARD ??!!!
HERE!!!
TAKE THIS BUTTPLUG
*Throws Buttplug*
find me some cigarittes
AND FUCK OFF !!!!!
i'm gonna have to hire my last girl Marlina
Marlina says : naturally
but she said naturally
BUT AIN'T NOTHING NATURAL ABOUT THAT GIRL
omg that money !!!
FINALLY!!!
finally i'm ruling the pimp business
my mom would be so proud of me if she looked at me right now.
the way i handle women with such dignity and respect.
even tumblr would approve of this video.
HAIL TO THE PIMP KING PEWDIEPIE!!!!!!
PIMPDIEPIE BITCH !!!!
THATS ME MOTHERFUCK--
*blaring noise*
Pewdiepie in this bitch with the 47 mil everybody wanna be him
Pimpin the titties the booby comittee is bouncin around and we shooting for 50
racks on racks I aint talking bout the cash got the boobies lookin at me and im feeling on her ass
bro fist to the friends staying down til the end got love for the fans and the haters never win
HOWS IT GOIN BROS
Felix in the cut with another funny clip, hit the sub won't miss, got the playlist jumpin,
audio bumpin, do it for the bros and you know we all love it
*DJBOOTYBUTT*